it's time for screen junkies movie bides
yeah look in the movie fights debut
deathmatch that's weird isn't it I'm
Spencer J Gilbert and today we have 9
count of 9 brand new fighters were gonna
be duking it out on this very stage for
the first time for the amazing prize
that we totally didn't buy on Amazon of
this large acorn with the ribbon around
it isn't that great isn't that special
yeah that's so lonely up here but before
we bring up before we bring up the first
group let's meet the judges
as always the professor lawn Harris
that's a good point
I watched this also next to him the
voice of the people Daniel Radford the
voice of the people Daniel Radford it's
so good to have you and you along with
my vote will break any ties and declare
the winner of each round but since is
the debut death match so be a little bit
different I'm three groups of Fighters
coming up three at a time
the winners from those rounds will go on
to a tiebreaker and the winner of the
tiebreaker which will just be two we'll
have a speed round he'll you've seen the
show before you know how it works
it's movie fights guys you ready let's
fight first group of fighters we have
the Schmo down in ER geekdom champion
mara Kaname
[Applause]
as amazing it's got a whole Model UN
worth of countries on it that's that's
cool
all right facing her he's the host of
the raging joy podcast it's our boss
[Applause]
hello hello
and she's a writer she's a comedian you
know her you love her it's clear Wiggins
[Applause]
and this is awesome
now I know if I were Hal Rudnick I'd say
something about owls and hoo-hoo Dan
demolition but I will not be doing that
that's his thing not mine sanction your
jewelry okay that said let's get this
going hit that package JT 13 it's
writing
all right okay you guys question number
one this is a doozy what movie from the
first half of this year most deserves to
be remembered come ask your time what
movie should I guess that means just get
a knob and Oscar nod any any category
and snub the obvious the following movie
Mara will begin with you alright well I
chose hereditary hereditary has all of
the components smashed together that
represent outstanding achievement in
Tony Colette's performance is phenomenal
horror movie or not her performance is
astounding you also have Alex wolf who
delivers an amazing jarring gripping
performance it's rooted in subtlety and
it's very very powerful but you can't
ignore the technical achievements of
hereditary the sound design the sound
editing and mixing is integral to the
effectiveness of the story and
establishing the atmosphere that is so
effective you also have cinematography
the lighting and the use of imagery in
that movie with shadow silhouetting and
how they compose the movie is amazing as
well as the actual editing of the film
because the pacing it establishes this
slow build burn up to a huge third after
climax so for those reasons and more I
chose ready time right got a lot of
breaths
Erik what do you got I chose sorry to
bother you hmm boots Riley was able to
tackle
racial inequality societal poisoning
based based on capitalism working-class
issues and took a satirical shot to
exploitative an art and entertainment
put it into a ball throw that perfect
Hail Mary spiral into a hell you have a
film and sadly I don't think it will be
remembered but it should but it should
what it should awesome clean what's your
pick my pick is Black Panther I picked
it largely because its cultural impact
it satisfies that whole Oscars trying to
pick a populist movie it has incredible
also cinematography sound
to editing it has it reflects that
diaspora of Africa in a way that's never
been seen on film before and I think in
a way that is way more effective than a
film like sorry to bother you sorry
sorry to say sorry bother you the
costume design the set design were
phenomenal so for those reasons and more
I picked black panther okay three good
movies why are the others terrible none
of them are terrible yeah I would say
Black Panther is completely out because
there's no way the Academy is going to
forget Black Panther in order for them
to remember they have to forget it
Black Panther is everywhere it was the
the the Academy even decided to true or
at least they tried to decide or toyed
with the idea of creating a most popular
film category based a lot about that
black panther and it's worth my problem
is is that sorry to bother you is a
fantastic film but doesn't but was
released early in January and in the
summer and as the winter months go on
people are thinking oh hey black
Klansmen or they're going into you know
the fall with the period pieces and
though I I don't understand my son and
while I still love him anyway type
movies that Oscar Oscar Fair that you
know something Benedict Cumberbatch is
gonna do but this is an original film
and not just a franchise ploy well I
would say that it's actually not that
original because it really to me
reflects the same old tired trope of a
slave narrative just repackaged for
today because it's still people who are
working for free and then literally at
the end of the movie spoiler alert they
get turned into beasts of burden so it's
basically just another 12 years lives
but with your party
spoilers I want to circle back around a
black panther though I think that the
Academy has demonstrated recently that
they do with knowledge superhero movies
particularly in the category of I can't
say they're everywhere Academy Award
winning Suicide Squad yeah they are
definitely not ignoring the more
technical aspects and and makeup and
costumes of superhero movies nowadays so
I do ignore black movies and that movie
is unapologetically black I can't
necessarily speak to that I think we can
all agree though that I mean championing
diversity in the Academy Awards is
obviously really important so I kind of
want to stick to the movies themselves
just in terms of I think we universally
agree yeah these are sad contribute yeah
I would I would Toni Collette is great
in heredity she should be remembered the
rest of the movie I don't really I don't
really say it's a great horror film
there was nothing really new or special
about it and honestly there were some
points it was just it just felt like a
slog nothing you were slow the intro
alone they had to use special lenses to
go into that dollhouse and seamlessly
merge it great it also took three
minutes for me to just ah just because
you have issues with being impatient
doesn't mean that that movie and at the
same time it doesn't really in terms of
story and narrative it's felt like
something I own or II see how this baby
meets Exorcist three much more
complicated dynamics of family and
including that inside I don't understand
my son and daughter well I still love
them isn't really what it was about at
all no I know I was just ripping off my
oscar bid i did earlier but
pay off it's fine I just that whether or
not you liked the movie personally you
cannot argue with the technical
execution of this movie it is it is the
example that movies should have as far
as how to use lighting just in I don't
think it's Oilers maybe there's a scene
where you are supposed to be looking at
something and the focal point ends up
being something that's not in the
foreground and they use subtle changes
in light to draw your attention to this
thing that ends up becoming the jolting
point for the third act climax and it is
genius
much like your movies like you're
arguing basically the scientific merits
of the movie and so it will be a horror
movies have a historically also won
Academy Awards for things like set
design and lighting and editing
Rosemary's Baby there there's a lot
visually going on with sorry to bother
you as well there's a lot of choices
made in terms of color in terms of light
in terms of shading in terms of shot
composition that I could easily argue
the same thing in terms of story and
originality and let's frankly face it
humor I just think that where the
argument is about deserves to be
remembered come Oscar time and sadly
this movie due to the lack of fun lack
of like a Disney Corporation of
marketing toward it and being
overshadowed by what's going on in which
remind you all of our movie choices will
be overshadowed by whatever period piece
is going to be but I think starting to
bother you has the past the best
performances has the best script and all
that and it's going to be drowned based
on when it was released coming out take
that as your as your closing statement
and I'd like to hear from ara and and
Cleve for why yours is uniquely suited
as opposed to these two uniquely
deserving first of all I want to point
out that the Academy has made a willful
decision to acknowledge the validity of
superhero movies the last ten years
which we can kind of agree that is the
when superhero movies have become good
enough to merit consideration
they've been nominated multiple times I
mean you've seen things like The Dark
Knight obviously again Academy
award-winning Suicide Squad if you want
to go
even further back Batman Forever had
Academy Award nominations but the last
notable Academy Award nomination for a
horror movie was back-to-back misery
Silence of the Lambs the Academy snubs
horror movies and the technical
achievements that are objectively there
as well as the range in the performances
and the descent into that madness that's
portrayed by Toni Collette and Alex wolf
would undeniably be a tragedy for it to
be forgotten
alright Clete okay well I mean it that's
not necessarily true that becoming Norse
horror movies because we did have get
out last year
that's a hybrid movie well that is
debatable that's another topic but I
mean I would call it a horror movie for
myself but I would say that that black
panther is uniquely qualified because I
think it's the first superhero movie
that is deserving of a Best Picture
nomination as well as all of the
scientific achievements that superhero
movies do traditionally get you're right
in that regard but I do think it merits
a Best Picture recognition whereas I
don't think sorry to bother you or
heredity are like would be something
that's not anybody would consider to be
best picture of the year awesome alright
time was crazy law and how the facts on
that they're not actually new comers cup
facts for you all the facts seem clean
to me alright Danielle were they saying
on them channels um so I haven't I
haven't gotten a whole lot of the
dankmemes yet someone did post a great
picture of you sitting by yourself
just like my birthday these 2049 that'll
be good can we give Spencer the trophy
feel bad I know where to get these
all right cool so yeah LAN help me out
I'm gonna go to you first
Wow it's tough because I thought
everybody made really good argue
especially the opening salvos from
everybody we're very strong I think
these aren't three great movies so this
was a really tough pick I have to say in
the end I felt like the least amount of
shots were taken and were sport against
hereditary and Mara I thought she had a
really great open excel though I didn't
really hear a lot about people taking it
away from hereditary said like you sort
of it was boring it's kind of kind of
suggest subjective
I actually think sorry to bother you
would have probably been my answer for
this and I thought Eric did a great job
of establishing sort of like here are
all of the things that it's sort of
doing in juggling but in the end I just
felt like Mara had the most effective
argument so I'm going hereditary fair
enough yeah Eric you did awesome all
three of you should be back cover many
many times I thought that you know you
kind of undercut your own argument
saying toni collette should be nominated
and and that your movie will be snubbed
that's not what you're here to fight
come back to me come January that's all
I'm saying
man this was just toe to toe back and
forth back and forth and I well mari you
laid out such a wide-ranging and
comprehensive argument for hereditary
everything you lobbed at Clichy punched
right back
she had a counter for for ignoring
horror films and the fact that it deals
with that kind of music nord black films
in the past there was a never set back
and forth and i think you answer just so
well that I'm going Klee we're gonna
have to go to the people
mara I'm sorry you're bounced your belt
upside down and it's a drive is it I did
OCD nation
she was doing the arguments y'all carry
it so right now on the poll we have with
57% hereditary
we've got sorry to bother you with 22%
and black panther with 20 congresso
morrow you're busy
any ones you guys are so awesome now
your time is up we got three more
amazing fighters back in that couch area
coming to the table number one she's the
managing editor editor at fandom
it's Keeley for a new office mate
welcome to the table next up she's a
writer and host of everything comes up
Simpsons Oh Julia Prescott
[Applause]
and last but not least you know you love
them from hyper RPG it's Cameron right
welcome all
finally we're talking about musicals
stars barn opens this weekend guys what
movie musical should get a remake are we
ready for this what movie musical should
be remade stars barns been remade
eighteen times but I hear the best
started with this chair last time so
let's start with Juliet to pick my pick
was the Beatles jukebox musical of the
early 2000s how could we possibly forget
it Julie Tamra's directorial debut for
the screen across the universe but
across the universe should be remade
with exclusively the music ography
what's the word I'm looking for the
Spencer that word of the Dave Matthews
because it would have just taken place
on the Sun and it would have just been
them walking on it no but
that was a slow bird but I got a people
in the next retire and all-star Julie
thank you so much I have to be frank
I've never actually listened to the Dave
Matthews Band I felt like this was an
appropriate choice because I understand
how Hollywood works a lot of budgets are
going up and down you know mid budget
movies aren't being made anymore because
it's either Marvel movies or super super
low indie Swiss army man kind of stuff
this movie appeals to both because we
can get Dave Matthews Band on board they
can play themselves in it and if you
take place entirely in a parking lot
it's gonna be called the space between
that point before you take drugs after
you've left your mom's lift rides we can
hit it could be a family film there's
probably gonna be some father-son [ __ ]
I'm sorry that we could explore with
this it could also be something that you
could bring your friends if you're if
you happen to be 13 you go on here first
maybe pg-13 r-rated movie journey and it
could be you know just everything that
you want and more Thank You Julie that
was a lot of words
next have you ever seen talented people
go along with their careers and
eventually they have to do a piece of
work that go and they go I guess I have
to do this because people expect me to
and they don't really try I present you
with Tim Burton Sweeney Todd and that's
the film I think should be remade the
fact of the matter is Sweeney Todd is
this amazing beautiful operatic dark
dark comedy that Stephen Sondheim made
in the 70s and they gave it to Tim
Burton because it seems like that's
going to be the hot topic musical so
they gave it to him and he cast to
people who everyone claims can sing but
I guess they were directed not to and
this movie Bumble their way through it
which is what you want for opera singing
it's a blah movie it doesn't it's not on
the radar for any of the people who are
involved in it despite the fact that it
got nominated for a couple things I
might even won Best Screenplay I don't
know nobody knows this movie do
practically shouldn't even exist which
makes it a bad movie because the at
least was something like across the
universe it's so strange and weird you
remember it there's nothing worse than
just existing and just being there as a
piece of art and that's what Sweeney
Todd is and I think you can update that
give it to an interesting director who
can do dark comedy put in a cast who can
sing and I guess Stephen Sondheim
actually involved outside of just doing
interviews where he goes I liked it I
guess all right fair enough
keely okay this is tough because I
really can't argue with Dave Matthews
Band musical in a part of I'd like to
team up so my I really think that adding
the musical that should be remade the
move musical that should be remade is
The Sound of Music and I basically it's
for one reason and one reason alone I
want to see car DB head The Sound of
Music
Julie Andrews movie with apart needy and
I just think I mean like who wouldn't
pay $15 to see her rap the lonely
goatherd in and of itself is like worth
it to me but I also just think like from
a pragmatic point of view um you know it
was made in in 65 it was made in 1965 at
one like pretty much every Academy Award
in 1966 Julie Andrews herself like we
have the Mary Poppins reboot or not
reboot it's a sequel time yeah yeah yeah
exactly the boot quote coming up and you
know she gave her stamp of approval on
that we have Emily Blunt who's gonna
take on that mantle she's fantastic but
um when people started asking Julie
Andrews about you know rebooting Mary
Poppins they also asked her about Sound
of Music and in an interview of Peter
Travers she signed off on it she was
like it's been like over 50 years it's a
great musical like it stood the test of
time someone else should take up that
mantle she didn't say it should be cardi
B but like she didn't not say so yeah so
that's my I feel very strongly excellent
excellent
openings so I'll open it up to the floor
fight it out who's mr. ban trap
Christopher Plummer is a thirst trap in
that movie is Hugh Jackman
[Laughter]
for you but you've got to get one of the
younger scarce cards you're really
facing serenity with the creepy one the
bill was into that role and like gives
birth to all of the Von Trapp children
then I'm on I don't want you to give
birth then because this is like the
dream she finds a hot widowed naval
captain she goes in and gray shits
herself with his children very same rich
for life that's the dream Germany is
escaping trumps America we had that kind
of remake it was called Annie not a bad
point I can see that that is not a bad
point but at the same time I feel like
Annie
they didn't remake it enough it was
still a me yes but they didn't make any
bold new choices with it if cardi B is
my bold new choice you know what I mean
this sounds like an amazing pitch for an
original film and you stole the title of
across the spiritual sequel okay the
title
I mean it's crashed into me because
obviously that's going to be the
Universal Studios ride no crashing into
a face of Dave Matthews yeah busted
stuff and I want it to be a two-volume
musical I wanted to be like the cursed
child but it has to be a whole yes I
want this it needs to be its own movie
it doesn't need to be the troll to of
across the universe where it's not
actually connected well yeah okay forget
the disconnect but yes
Ryde thing because i would also share
that i am fresh from a week-long
vacation in Orlando where I woman in her
I feel like movies used to be made for
you know DVD sales or what comes after
movies are made now just as a face for
the theme park ride mantas service you
know China uses the mummy indoor
rollercoaster with Jurassic Park the
water adventure that's great I would
like to have it's a small world
rebranded for the car DB Sondheim mi say
is that the way
- they're in the car theater major
so why don't we I probably miss that
part know I think the fact of the matter
is is I feel like this was a lazily made
movie by people who could do better I
think it was miscast Johnny Depp was -
at this point young and attractive
Sweeney Todd should have some age on him
he's been through some [ __ ] and I think
it a lot of people whenever you try and
tell people like the song a movie they
go well Alan Rickman and Alan Rickman is
amazing but we do not let Batman and
Robin go because of Michael Gough and we
do not Haley vs. predator go because of
Lance Henriksen one good rule does not
excuse a bad movie I'm gonna stop your
argument right there say that we already
got a reboot of Sweeney Todd and it was
that one clip drinking wine in his
[Music]
career with it Julie is saying but I
also say the reboot was Amber Heard and
Johnny Depp apologizing for bringing
their dog to Australia and I'm still
basking I will say that the one the one
aspect sure that I disagree on in
Sweeney Todd is that I love the Tim
Burton aesthetic where it's like
everyone is like in white makeup and
they've been like locally like
electrocuted and everyone's hair is like
as an aesthetic as because Johnny Depp
could not wear wear a hat they gave him
a crazy wig yeah I agree it's a great
crazy wig outside of that though Tim
Burton's awesome aesthetic in the 80s
and 90s was because he was from
animation Hughes claymation and
animation all those other stuff that
when the Joker Falls in Batman it's
becomes oddly animated it's weird and
creepy and then Mars Attacks happened he
discovered CGI and it ruined him
Sweeny then we need someone who can do
dark comedy and I'm going back here you
guys all know way too much about Dave
Maass on the bridges that with this [ __ ]
about Sweeney Todd burn actually had
wanted to make a Sweeney Todd phone
since the early nineteen eighties it was
not brought down by the studio the phone
number of boards Goldie Globe for Best
Picture Musical or Comedy Depp won Best
Actor Musical or Comedy
the film also won an art an Oscar for
best art direction is Sondheim it is
Lance Henriksen but it is Michael
right about troll 2 it was made under
the title of goblins and they changed
the name to troll 2 just to make it
sound like it was related to troll it
was not our musical theater audience
have to say about this damn yeah so
really quickly I wanna I got a great
tweet from pumpkin Queen McGee
paint great name it's her 3 year wedding
anniversary and her husband David loves
movie fights they're watching live and
they were wondering if we could give
them a shout out she wants to see her
face
you better have gotten that camera I
told you to get happy anniversary folks
happy I don't understand why we're not
taking this seriously
cardi B 25 years old 49
on every level so what was the age gap
between Julie Andrews and Christmas card
I didn't think we need to do better look
I don't know I don't want to find our
own fans on this because the people who
say why aren't you taking this seriously
annoy me because part of this game is
creativity and I value that very much as
a judge so I almost want to spitefully
pick Dave Mann the chat might have
driven me to doing that even though
because Cameron you pitched the only
actual movie difference is I don't know
how you could reconcile because most
important things that they're still
lederhosen that's the only sticking
point yeah but it was modern day and
Trump's America and then and still
dressed like it just seemed too bizarre
so it's it's really you know a the safe
choice or the risk I'm giving it to
Julia for the risk I would have actually
wanted to see I have a feeling that I'll
be overruled by lon and in the chat so
let's hear it what do you guys get if
you want to go first and only six years
difference between Julie Andrews and
Christopher Plummer no it was 13 was 36
she was 31 they may say okay so here is
the pole as of right now and again the
pole is not actually count until all the
judges have said their thing but as of
right now the chat is going 42% for
Sweeney Todd 29% for across the universe
and 28% instead of musica 30 beat
I hate to put you in the swing spot put
me in the sweet spot I have thoughts on
this one so Cameron pitched I think the
most like this is a thing that could
actually happen I could see memory doing
sweetie taught hmm
I do have to give it up for Julia for
such an adventurous creative pitch when
I first heard it I was like no way this
is gonna fly by the end I was like I
would watch this damn madman subsequent
news ago I'm given her the win yeah
[Applause]
we can joy sequel to the Dave Matthews
one and it's just smooth we'll see you
back momentarily you all deserve a place
here at the table but you know who else
does group number three let's bring up a
home do we have anyone else the producer
it's green Chucky's max - yeah hey you
work here you know this next guy he's
from the Schmo down from action movie
Anatomy it's a new guy and she is a
hilarious comedian and writer it is
Vanessa that's a tough act to follow
guys but I think this one will be
equally entertaining question number
three a female lead Fast and the Furious
spin-off movie could be in the works
what actress should be the Vin Diesel of
a female lead fast and furious and make
sure you include in your answer what
being a female pin diesel means to you a
lot specifically what vegan
like a female Vin Diesel means to me
because I feel like the number one thing
not just to be like the lead but the Vin
Diesel and a fast and furious character
the most important thing is being able
to say the word family over 200 times in
a two-hour span about passing out and
taraji B Henson says family like a
thousand times a minute on Empire like
cooking lion could be a phenomenal Dom
for like some really specific reasons
like in the very underrated smokin aces
and in-crowd Mary she's done the action
thing before she's done the career
criminal thing before but also she's
done the hard and soft thing that only
da man like Vin Diesel can portray cuz
like there's a lot of camp to it and it
needs to be someone that could take camp
seriously and she's done like I think
like a few two or three Tyler Perry
movies so she knows camp but like she
knows camp but she loves camp but also
like proud mary had that maternal part
of her and she was also the mom and
Karate Kid so and if you need to be like
a very parental figure to be dumped so
she could do like the hard the soft the
camp in the same family a thousand times
a minute without passing out okay and
she's got it yeah she was the Mohammed
Karate Kid thank you I think there's
only one person and it's Tessa Thompson
to me Vin Diesel Dominic Toretto is all
about swagger mmm-hmm and look at that
picture I mean she's got swagger
who's an out of her sorry effortlessly
school she's got range she can do
anything she's been and obviously
Valkyrie and thor ragnarok she can kick
but she's been and all different kinds
of movies which I'll get into she's been
in dear white people she's gonna do
comedy she's been in West world she's a
boss
she's been an annihilation she has a
vulnerable side she could do anything
and she's the perfect anchor for a
all-female led Fast and Furious spin-off
okay Andrew who's your pick I'm gonna
have to go with gal gadot and the reason
for this is between the motherly hood
and the easing is that she's actually so
sorry
she's actually a mother she's a mother
of two and if you want to talk about
being motherly and the things that
encapsulate dominic toretto it's about
him being the father of the entire
family so gal is about the exact same
age that Vin Diesel was when he did this
tragic piece 50 no offense to taraji
it's just you got a 28-7 more
installments she is she is 48 I was
speaking for dramatic effect but she's
gonna do seven more sequels okay and
then Tessa Thompson I love it but she's
not a mom you got to be a mom you gotta
be you gotta understand what it's like
to take care of a family she's also been
in four of the films but not in the most
recent one so where has she been
throwing together her crew
that's right Tessa Thompson might be
their tragic she probably won't be but
honestly gal gadot here she's trained in
the Israeli military you know she used
to be in the service she could kick some
ass like Dominic does in those films so
look you got a mom she drives the car at
the end of Fast Five we all fell in love
with her then you want to talk about
swagger maybe not using Wonder Woman are
you kidding me like this is this is open
and closed gal gadot thank you
all right fight it out guys think gal
gadot is one completely disqualifying
thing which is that she was in Fast and
Furious right she played Gisele when she
died no no no so we have a disaster you
have you've never seen the faster
Furious movies she can jump finger
demonstration or tallest buildings in
what would be in China now that that's
the new Hollywood instead of in Dubai
her twin sister could be back to avenge
her death jumping from the fourth to the
third to the second to the tallest
building going up this time and set it
down
okay firstly that's assuming also that
they're gonna have like a million other
lady Fast and the Furious reboots
afterwards but usually when there's an
all-female reboot you get one like
ghostbusters you get one I think
oceans eight you get one no this year
they never know they might be making
another one well I've seen the industry
but like in this case it's it's gonna be
a one-time thing she's 48 she's younger
than Vin Diesel like she could do it I
know but have you seen her skin
I like Tessa Thompson but I don't like
her for Vin Diesel I think she's the
Paul Walker character Tessa Thompson
isn't the Vin Diesel type she's a Paul
Walker type and gal gadot is the Roman
type like if we're going for the Vin
Diesel not if they fit and fast in the
Furious but the Vin Diesel is taraji who
could do the hard the soft the leader
but also like I have a past and I'm
romancing this young man hard and soft
like you you qualified taraji by saying
she could say a word 200 times without
passing out like I could probably do
that right now without passing out right
yes yeah and then you do we have time
let's give 15 seconds see how many times
you can say it's in to our movies so you
know all right we have on the clock in
five to one family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family fan family
family family gotta go for effect you
know for Groot he did like over 20,000
recordings there's a man that takes his
time okay Vin Diesel has to have this
air of danger he's from the streets she
was in the military duty line his server
in the mid sheet taught black kill gal
gadot it was but nothing that she's ever
performed on camera shows that she's
always kind of sweet in in Fast and
Furious she's kind of eye candy
unfortunately
I'm thoroughly impressed by you she's
intimidating because of her powers she's
very sweet she's and there's like this
overriding sweetness and goodness -
you're right it's a stature thing yeah
and the power comes from like we know
she's Wonder Woman you guys are all
talking about gala right now because no
one's talking about Roger you're Tessa
oh because it's an easy-open shut it
Suraj
top Singh has proven that she can fight
one thing that is fine about ticket
sales then if I'm gonna talk Hollywood
and movies Galkin sell ticket sales
Tessa can't her and nella tested even
make 70 million dollars and also with
taraji P Henson I mean like of course
there's gonna be ticket sales like her
Mac line when she came out with a
lipstick sold out that's when I'll buy
her makeup I'm not gonna go watch her
movies opening weekend do you know how
women spend money I mean I'm right proud
Mary was her taking a shot at being an
action star and it did not work
unfortunately marketing she's done
action star before or is it because that
she couldn't hack it as an action star I
think
ultimately you want to start a franchise
that can go seven or eight movies so how
about someone who's a little bit's a
mother of two that's been in the
military that can show that she can
carry a movie and sell tickets I don't
know she sounds like my Dominic Toretto
you don't have to be a mom to play a mom
though like I only got two guinea pigs
but I'm pretty sure I give you a dope
mom on screen it's not about personal
experience it's about what you can
portray and Tessa Thompson has portrayed
all of the angles of Dominic Toretto she
has the swagger as valkyrie she's got
the sweet side and Creed she's got the
vulnerability she's got the badass boss
of Westworld she's coming up in many way
again just listicles she's hanging on
her is carrying a franchise with men in
black and in annihilation she says she
has a range she can do but she can't
sell tickets in the whole thing about
fashion carriers they're betting on her
in men in black that they're betting on
a lot of other people and then in black
too if you look at annihilation the two
leads were Tessa Thompson and Natalie
Portman Academy Award winner at Natalie
Portman that movie made 43 million
dollars in the u.s. it was dumped by the
studio before you gonna change
Annihilation couldn't stand a chance
entirely based on like just the studio
not backing it up like it's definitely
not a case of Natalie Portman or tested
not being able to sell it the marketing
is what tanked it and a lot of these
like both with Toronto and Tessa they
are an objectively phenomenal movies
that the studio's weren't backing like
watch smokin aces now and tell me if you
can't see taraji drifting around a
corner and leading a heist like watch it
clear now 15 years ago when it came out
I mean like there's been so many
opportunities for her to like display
that like smokin aces and an empire is
where I bring it up like watch taraji
walk out in a fur coat with like
thousands of dollars of jewels
alright time nicely done y'all
[Laughter]
factor that in wow that was intense that
was fast that was furious lon what do
you got
that was fast in fear both faster Gary's
we might get an oceans a sequel still up
in the air we don't know for sure
gal gadot was infecting the Israeli
Defense Forces at combat instructor for
two years and the diesel said I am Groot
about 1,000 times when they were there
you go those are your bag it's beautiful
what are they saying in the chest
Danielle um well in the chat oh here's a
really good a tweet from all about
underscored ECU says I vote me a
Jovovich Resident Evil franchise is just
as ridiculous as fast to the Furious she
can obviously handle action movies I
like her um wait is it mere Jovovich
about the things wrong one man well as I
say why we're learning also to
pronunciation we're in Southern
California here that's he and the chat
was already hoping someone would pick
Tessa Thompson so they were super
stressed about that also if it's Tessa
Thompson that means that we get her
girlfriend Janelle Monae on the
soundtrack where are you leaning Wow
this was a really good round I got a lot
of good audience but I have to say I
love Vanessa's opening taraji P Henson
argument and I really didn't hear a
takedown that I thought was like sort of
that convincing like yeah proud Mary
didn't didn't really open up but it was
under promoted III think taraji piensa
would be amazing in this Vanessa hey so
many good points all around Vanessa you
really laid out a comprehensive list for
why she's qualified max you said the
word who's really
the Proud Mary was the biggest
counterpunch landed that was a variant
that was a hurdle but but maybe
undeserved point but but fair play fair
play and yeah I think that I couldn't
quite get over the twin sister plot
contrivance oh it is that's just like a
concession to we don't care anybody that
to be brought up yeah it's all good
choices but I gotta give it to Vanessa
congratulate a stop with 30% and Gow
with 38 nice okay but you're working
right now we now have the tiebreaker so
when all the winners come back up I
believe that's Maura
can I get Vanessa back and and Julia
back to the stage
[Applause]
look at that okay so you guys have not
prepared anything for this you don't
know what I'm gonna ask do you know okay
all right well this is not an easy one
but the way this is gonna work is you
will shout out your answer and once
you've been once you've shouted all
three of you shouted you'll each have 20
seconds to argue for your choice and now
you're just playing not to lose the
worst answer will be eliminated so one
person will go to will remain for the
speed round y'all ready yeah okay
everyone's been raving about Matt Damon
on SNL he was so funny as Cavanaugh what
movie features who features the best
surprise Damon yes what's the best Matt
Damon cameo shout it out when you got
any ahead Thor Ragnarok Team America
world police euro trip okay
great work all around let me just write
this so I don't forget Authority Leo
remind me what yours was Team America
world America and Amara with euro trip
alright 20 seconds on the clock who
answered first Vanessa yeah okay we will
start with you when you start speaking
Matt Damon plays Loki in the reenactment
of what Loki says happened in Thor
Ragnarok and I love that because Matt
Damon also played Loki in Dogma which
implies that Loki has the time to watch
a Kevin Smith movie enjoy it like Matt
Damon's portrayal and cast him as
himself
in play which yeah who a second me all
right Julia that was really good say to
America world police we of course know
this to be the Matt Damon cameo that
never happened and that's what makes it
great because no Damon is a good Damon
just have somebody phonetically fumbling
through mid Damon then you've got comedy
cold because I like a Matt Damon that's
still sitting on this couch and can't be
bothered alright and Mara with Eurotrip
when you start talking alright don't
stall for time your trip is fantastic
because it is kind of the moment where
we defined what the Matt Damon cameo
really was it was entirely unexpected it
was actually so subtle I didn't
recognize him right away
it's hilarious it fuels the plot without
feeling like a pot device and the idea
that no Damon is a good Damon anyone
could have been made fun of by saying
their name in a slow kind of funny way
that wasn't unique to Matt Damon in any
way it could have been a joke for anyone
Wow alright hot fire hot fire being sin
it sorry
oh we have ten seconds well in that case
let's go back around begin with you
rebuttal Matt Damon's MCU canon Matt
Damon exists in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe which means if Loki was able to
watch a Kevin Smith movie I want to know
yep that I'm a rebuttal for mine um it
couldn't be any person that could have
not been there no demon is a good demon
because having that demon not be there
and having them just say his name really
weird suggests that they are friends and
he could have showed up but he did it
mara and you ready okay the Loki is Loki
as Loki thing is too deep of a cut for
the average viewer to have recognized
which is really unfortunate because it
is cool and as far as no demon is a good
daemon it could have been Bruce Willis
and it would have been just as effective
no it wouldn't have let's go to the
couch first and yell you'll be speaking
for yourself this time which you love oh
yeah this is the point where I love you
the poles are gone I have a person these
arguments were all incredibly amazing
and funny and I'm dead I will say that
Mara had the strongest argument for me I
gotta go with remember we're voting for
the one you hate I know it's brutal this
is not worthy friends oh man um I oh
gosh they were all so funny and I died I
Julian had the funniest but not best
argument funny is run out lon where do
you go I invited you to my wedding
this was this was very tough but in the
end you know I thought I heard the least
amount of very compelling points for
Eurotrip so I think I would keep Giulia
and Vanessa and Maura very sorry but I
think I would send her home this round
you know I thought that Maura made the
most plot critical arguments for a Damon
cameo for why it was intrinsic to the
movie as well which counted a lot for me
and your Loki deep cut was just
incredible that was great Julia just
wrote down yelling so but I'm not quite
sure where you're going with it and that
was a good Bruce Willis point so my
wedding invite got lost in the mail so
[Music]
[Applause]
serious business
and you know what else is serious the
speed round that's right this is now a
game of best-of-five the scores are
being wiped clean so we will be asking
up to five first two three five speed
round questions same rules apply you
have 20 seconds to answer ten second
rebuttals just yell it out when you have
the answer in your head and we'll go
from there y'all ready yep yo okay we
begin with question number one Chris
Evans days as Captain America seemed to
be at an end who would be the worst
replacement for him as Captain
Steve Buscemi why did I say that Al
Pacino
[Music]
[Applause]
vanessi answered first so you will begin
so I'm gonna are you with myself with
Steve Buscemi wouldn't make a great cap
he'd make an interesting x-men side
character for like a weird interesting
power but he's not the best leader type
I can't imagine as a leader he's a
permanent sidekick also I can't ever
imagine him as your suave debonair
captain type even though I personally
think Steve Buscemi can get it this is
the worst person to replace them right
okay make sure Al Pacino is way past his
good days of acting and I think you do
have to have a strong actor who can
still put out good work Steve Buscemi
and Boardwalk Empire is incredible he
proves that he still has the chops to go
out there and give a performance that's
demanding Al Pacino just goes up there
and hacks it up as dunkaccino I mean
that's unlike no other thing Tucson and
it was awful he would be terrible as
Captain America ten seconds
Steve Buscemi can play a fantastic
villain type you can play a fantastic
sniveling partner type but you can't
play a like heroic leader everyman type
Al Pacino there's been a Latino it's all
I need
just because someone hasn't done
something it doesn't mean it's not in
their wheelhouse we've seen a lot of
different actors make turns from like
comedy to drama and vice versa in ways
that have been really effective and I
think that Steve Buscemi just proved
that he's too talented hmm well done
Maura I think you hit back too hard on
those points and Vanessa by saying Steve
Buscemi can get it you really understand
like every movie goer does but me I like
a good bug I doesn't want a mask anymore
really so you've done pissy and those so
that first point for me goes tomorrow
but let's hear from the other judges
I thought Maura definitely won this one
for me just overall I thought a lot a
lot of great points and yeah like
Vanessa sort of too kind
okay Danielle we'll get you next time
question number two it looks like the
lethal weapon show lost both of its
leads eighties eighties action movie
franchise should replace Lethal Weapon
as a TV show
I just forgot every eighties action
movie I've ever seen
if it really was cop damn it all right
i'ma i'ma give it to uh oh man I haven't
seen I've only seen a lot of like John
Hughes stuff type all right let's give
it to another Karate Kid
reboot okay Carly Kid the series versus
Beverly Hills Cop the series Mara you
start Beverly Hills Cop is a show that
can translate directly from when it was
made to today there's still many
interesting antics to have within law
enforcement plus we've seen like a show
about law enforcement even though it's a
more serious show laundr Duras be used
on its 20th season we already have Cobra
Kai so I kind of think that Karate Kid
might have already been done and
possibly been done better than it could
be as far as a new reboot so I would go
with the real cop we're already seeing a
lot of really interesting shows about
like examining masculinity and I feel
like a MMA version a series of karate
kid' would be fantastic because then we
have that older type character that's
coaching like a younger kid in the ring
but it's also examining like what it is
to be a man like are you an aggressor or
someone that like protects yourself and
especially now when yes Morrow ten
seconds well one thing that Beverly
Hills Cop has the opportunity to do as
far as gender dynamics is actually
including a female main cast member we
don't have to recast all of these male
roles as men this allows us to say
something about what we're going through
societally without being having ended a
UFC reboot would actually let us cast a
lot of women because as long as
somebody's in the same weight class they
can fight each other so we can have an
all-female Cobra Kai just merge in these
UFC boys that are like The Karate Kid
type all right good stuff let's go to
Danielle first um you know once again
fantastic arguments I have to say on
this one Vanessa had the stronger
argument interesting I do think that you
both had super strong arguments and and
there's no way of really knowing this
without watching it but I do think that
Cobra Kai covers a lot of the same
masculinity ground and she did bring up
Cobra Kai so I'm gonna go with Mara this
one LAN who'd yeah yeah I've got kind of
same way the MMA twist is an interesting
one and a new
and that I thought was interesting in
that kind of carrier this is argument
some of the way for me but Mara I
thought closed out and Beverly Lescott
sounds like the more original fresh take
all right Vanessa you're on the ropes i
watch that though definitely before
lethal weapon for short so we go into
question number three jon favreau
release some new info about his
Mandalorian Star Wars show what's the
best movie ever written directed by or
featuring Jon Favreau I'm gonna give it
to swingers swingers I'm gonna go for
Iron Man okay swingers versus Iron Man
Vanessa
when you're ready firstly swear is just
a beautiful graveyard of Los Angeles
landmarks that some exist now and some
don't exist anymore just the intro and
everywhere they go is such a fascinating
love letter to the city of Los Angeles
and not just like the Hollywood
Boulevard that people know and Jon
Favreau amongst like this guy friendship
movie created this like testament to the
city part of the reasons why we have
amazing superhero movies now is because
of what happened in 2008 with Iron Man
it was proving that you can have a
fantastical concept about a guy that
wears a suit full of metal and goes and
shoots himself in the air and then
shoots things that other people can be
riveting it could be interesting and it
could be worthy of sequels he also
proved that you can be in your own movie
and not look like a total douche and
it's great to have a love letter to LA
but I would rather have I feel like
blade was the first superhero movie that
could tell you that superheroes would be
the concept that actually works and
there hasn't really been anything like
swingers sink swingers like we wouldn't
have the hangover or a lot of like
friend movies without it I would say
since blade came out in 1998 and there
was a ten-year gap between the next
really good superhero movie that that's
kind of a moot point and if we want to
talk about a love letter to LA there was
lala land that was literally the movie
just did it so I would say how do you
everything that is that it sound all
right that was that was tight
that was real tight la you start first
very close both great movies both great
arguments really came down to the wire
for me I thought
Vanessa's argument about swingers is
sort of a love land love letter to Los
Angeles more so than lala land I think
that that really sort of stuck with me
I'm giving this one to Vanessa but
slight edge yeah I'm leaning the same
way was just at the end I thought blade
was a really good counterpoint and then
I do think that at the end of the
hangover and movies of that ilk being
influenced by swingers was just enough
to put it over just all the reasons
Ironman is is good so that I got more
from Vanessa I'm giving it to you too
you're still in the game all right
fighting to stay alive at this question
number five really glad we got this one
here we go Clint Eastwood plays a drug
mule for the Mexican cartel in his new
movie the mule what movie character
would you trust the most to serve as
your drug mule the pigeon lady from home
alone two
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the Incredible Hulk
okay Vanessa again if you make the
Incredible Hulk nervous he's gonna give
it away but with the pigeon lady she has
an entire army of different creatures
that can't talk no matter how much you
interrogate them
thank you building you know fairly
unconfessed people want to ignore
pigeons already and they can't carry I
checked pigeons can carry about like
[Applause]
okay Maura I agree with the hilarious
premise that she's in conspicuous in the
net she has people that won't squeal but
number one you don't have to cross at
the border with the cops and everything
that Colonel Holt can just like jump
over the river he won't get caught he
doesn't need drugs and I would really be
seriously concerned that she would
actually use all of the drugs that I
would be wanting to have for myself the
whole doesn't need drugs he's already
hooked out and roided-out he doesn't
need any drugs so I would say that he
can get across undetected have you seen
a child a pigeon lady is she's
definitely not on any kind of
amphetamines just don't need to be paid
pigeons can't go to jail and you can
always get more without like harming
someone number one who says it has to be
in feta means that I'm smuggling number
one and number two her her behavior
could definitely say that she's on some
kind of drug for real like valium hello
just snort it that's what you got
manipulated with a simple hand touch
okay wow that was I'm something else
again I I you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
right a noble valiant effort against
what may have been an unbeatable page is
Vanessa that's one for the highlight
reel it's better than the first one in
my head Canon she is dealing drugs now
yes okay
finally Wow comes down to the last
question a great episode whoever loses
is still a winner that goes for everyone
watching a new trailer drop for the
reboot of pets and symmetry nice one
Billy Cemetery what is the scariest
movie animal scariest animal in film
mm-hmm
I must say that banks from hocus pocus
go by context here the crocodile from
Lake Placid okay
Thackeray let's hear it Vanessa I can
hide from a crocodile in most buildings
but have you seen a cat get to something
when it really wants it he has the
intelligence of a man plus he could give
me actual cat scratch fever not to
mention the fact that he is enchanted
he'll live forever
I can murk a crocodile I can't Mert
Zachary Zachary Zachary Zachary not just
that but isn't like cats really
dangerous a pregnant woman the question
is scariest that crocodile is terrifying
he eats people he eats Betty white for
goodness sake she's on the American
treasure she was literally older than
sliced bread cats can't get to you sure
cats can't scratch and give you fever
sure but that crocodile is an apex
predator that has survived for millions
of years do you think that you can
really just like kill it or run away
from it if it wants to get you it will
get you and you have to assume you're in
the environment or the samo exists I'm
never gonna be in the same room as a
crocodile but I'm in the room has a lot
of cats and if a cat just says words
it's something the scariest animal I've
ever met if it can say words and it
tells me confirm that witches are real
if we want to say that oh we can get
away from crocodiles sure I can get away
from cats I can go to China because
guess what they eat them there so I mean
that's legitimate Lee a fact it is in a
stereotypically fact that some tribal
areas of China still
okay Monday you start do they both great
arguments a lot a lot to chew on here
really I would be in person be a lot
more scared of the huge Lake Placid been
white devouring crocodile then I would
be a nice talking cat so I'm going with
Mara you would treasure Betty White
he is and law namely in the same way
just because the the crux of your of
your counter-argument that you could get
away from it I think crocodiles go can
crawl up onto the land right you think
they want to get you they're gonna get
you what's their land speed anything
stay away from hippos you guys but Marv
is our champion is that actually we are
never afraid of black cats because they
do not get adopted very often and they
are amazing I don't had a black cat but
I don't want one that talks I mean I'm
saying that's at least Phyllis and we
can take from this is that they're not
they can be talking and they can't they
cannot be scary to black cats so there
you go and for your cat's to play with
here is this thing that we've decided to
name the deathmatch you can open it yeah
there's
at once oh man guys I hope you all had
fun do we have a good time I honestly
think that just by sheer entertainment
value every single one of you earned a
place back here I think we'll be seeing
more of every single person will be
seeing Mara Erik CLE Keely Julia Cameron
max Andrew and Vanessa and lawn Harris
of course thank you all right well I
think that does it for fan fury right
for movie fights if you stuck around
this long congratulations you're the
real winner
but please hit us up at movie fights
hashtag move fights live no no no more
elves elves are dead to me but power I
make in the usual gang we'll be back
next week hope you had fun see you then
bye bye
you